digamos que esta es una célula entonces
sabemos que dentro de esta célula están
ocurriendo todo tipo de actividades
estudiaremos eso con más profundidad a
medida que avancemos en nuestro estudio
de biología pero es importante darse
cuenta de que esta célula no funciona de
forma aislada para vivir esta célula
necesita recursos del mundo exterior de
modo que los recursos deben atravesar
esa membrana exterior de la célula para
que puedan usarse dentro de la
maquinaria celular y a medida que la
célula hace lo que tiene que hacer
también se generan productos de desecho
que deben ser liberados de alguna manera
a través de esa membrana así que también
tenemos desechos y también se tiene
energía que es transferida ya sea del
interior de la célula hacia el exterior
o del exterior hacia el interior
muchas veces imaginamos que toda la
actividad que sucede dentro de la célula
genera energía térmica que tiene que ser
disipada de alguna manera y generalmente
ese es el caso aunque no siempre
tienes energía térmica que tiene que ser
disipada ahora probablemente veas algo
interesante o tal vez no te has dado
cuenta todavía y es que toda esta
actividad se lleva a cabo en el volumen
de la célula pero entonces todo este
intercambio todos los recursos que
entran y los desechos que salen la
energía térmica que va en las dos
direcciones
tiene que ser difundida de alguna manera
a través de la superficie a través de
esta superficie de dos dimensiones de
modo que esto nos plantea una pregunta
interesante a medida que aumenta el
volumen qué ocurre con la razón entre la
superficie y el volumen porque podrías
imaginar que tal vez en algún momento el
volumen podría ser tan grande que no
exista suficiente área en la superficie
como para que se realicen adecuadamente
estas tres cosas entonces pensemos en
esta razón pensemos en la razón entre el
área de superficie y el volumen me voy a
poner un poco matemática no es necesario
que conozcas las matemáticas para el
contexto de un curso de biología
necesitas saber cuál es la conclusión
que obtenemos de las matemáticas vamos a
ver si esta es una esfera de radio r el
área de esta superficie va a ser igual a
4 pi por erre cuadrada y el volumen de
esta esfera va a ser igual a cuatro
tercios de pi por r kubica
está pi se cancela con esta pi si
dividimos el numerador y el denominador
entre r cuadrada obtenemos 1 aquí y
obtenemos r justo aquí si dividimos
estos dos entre 4
aquí obtienes 1 y este va a ser un
tercio entonces nos queda 1 sobre un
tercio de r o podríamos reescribir esto
como 3 sobre r y entonces vemos que al
menos para una célula esférica como esta
a medida que aumenta r a medida que
nuestras células se hace cada vez más
grande la razón entre el área de la
superficie y el volumen disminuye dejen
de escribirlo a medida que aumenta la
razón entre el área de superficie y el
volumen disminuye a mayor denominador
menor será el valor y entonces lo que
esto nos dice es que a medida que
aumenta el volumen de nuestra célula a
medida que nuestras células se hace más
y más grande tenemos menos área de
superficie por unidad de volumen por lo
que esto hará que el intercambio de los
recursos del desperdicio y de la ned
o sea cada vez más difícil y
obtendríamos un resultado similar si en
lugar de hacer una célula esférica
digamos que ahora tenemos una célula
cúbica de gen hacerla así una célula
cúbica puedes ver esto en algunas
plantas algo que parece cubo o prisma
rectangular digamos que es x x x x x
podríamos hacer el mismo ejercicio a que
va a ser igual la razón entre el área de
superficie y el volumen bueno ahora en
nuestra área de superficie tenemos 6
caras y cada una tiene un área de x
cuadrada por lo que nuestra área de
superficie va a ser igual a 6 x cuadrada
y luego el volumen va a ser igual a x
por x por x sobre x a la tercera
potencia dividimos el numerador y el
denominador entre x cuadrada y vamos a
obtener 6 sobre x así que una vez más
puedes ver que en tanto x se incrementa
nuestra razón entre el área de
superficie y el volumen disminuye a
medida que nuestro denominador aumenta
todo
esta expresión va a disminuir entonces
conociendo este fenómeno es difícil que
existan células más grandes porque para
toda actividad que sucede en el volumen
de la célula no hay suficiente área de
superficie para hacer todo este
intercambio ahora hay cosas que vemos en
los sistemas biológicos que ayudan a las
células a llegar más allá de lo que
vemos aquí si imaginas la sección
transversal bidimensional de esta célula
una forma de aumentar el área de
superficie respecto al volumen es que la
membrana se vea más como ésta cuantos
más pliegues tenga mayor será la razón
entre el área de superficie y el volumen
y sin duda vemos esto muchas veces en
biología entonces cada vez que tengas
una razón alta entre el área de
superficie y el volumen se encontrarán
cosas como estos pliegues en las
membranas de las células hasta el
próximo vídeo